تعتبر الدبابات العمود الفقري للقوات
البريه حيث تجمع عناصر مختلفه فهي تؤمن
الكثافه الناريه والتبريح وقوه المدفعيه
والحركه لذلك تستخدمها الجيوش سلاحا
هجوميا وفي الاقتحامات وعلى الجبهات لكن
للدبابه كذلك تقليديا مدى رؤيه محدد من
الداخل وزوايا عمياء تمنع الطاقم من تحديد
الاهداف القريبه لذلك تحتاج دبابه كذلك
الى قوات المشاه لحمايتها بسبب ذلك وعند
دخول الدبابه الى المدن فانها تفقد قدره
المناوره ويصبح احتمال اقتراب المهاجمين
منها اكبر لقدرتهم على الاستفاده من
الزوايا العمياء لها حتى وان تم تركيب
الكاميرات لفحص المكان حول الدبابه فان
وجود الكتل الاسمنتيه يسمح للمهاجمين
بالاختباء والاقتراب منها ومبا غتها كما
ان وجود الانفاق له دور اخر في اخفاء
المقاتلين حيث يمكنهم الحركه مع صعوبه
كشفهم من قبل القوات اذ من الممكن في هذه
الحاله ان يظهر المهاجمون من تحت الارض
وليس من فوقها فقط ويستهدف المدرعه ويعطي
المدى القريب افضليه للمهاجمين في هذه
الحاله لذلك تعتبر المدن من اصعب البيئات
لعمل الدبابات وتحتاج الى الحمايه من قوات
المشا
التي بدورها تكون عرضه لرصد واستهداف
المدافعين عن المدينه المتخفين في الابنيه
او
الانفاق